el mensaje de navalny en la red social
instagram corrobora lo que ya había
dicho ayer el hospital charité aquí en
berlín donde está naval y desde hace
unas semanas el hospital había indicado
que naval ni puede ya respirar por su
propia cuenta es decir que fue retirado
de la respiración artificial que su
estado de salud continúa mejorando y que
puede desplazarse pocos metros de su
cama por periodos específicos
aún por supuesto lo que no está claro es
si hay algún impacto a largo plazo luego
del entrenamiento confirmado por las
autoridades alemanas las autoridades
alemanas por cierto también pidieron a
otros dos países de la unión europea a
suecia ya francia que realizara sus
propias investigaciones que también
corroboraron el entrenamiento con el
agente nervioso no que tomás otra
pregunta que surge no es qué implicación
podría tener esta mejoría de naval ni en
lo que son las investigaciones por
presunto envenenamiento y también para
las sean muy tensas no relaciones entre
rusia y la unión europea
una implicación muy concreta en términos
de seguridad para las autoridades
alemanas que ahora no solamente tienen
que preocupar preocuparse de la mejoría
de salud de nava ni sino también de su
seguridad a medida que su condición
mejora y puede recibir más visitas y es
muy cierto lo que ustedes dicen que las
relaciones ya muy tensas entre rusia y
alemania- y no solamente entre los dos
países no también te rusia y la unión
europea pues hay versiones encontradas
sobre exactamente qué fue lo que le pasó
a naval ni en cuanto al caso alemán a la
posición alemana alemán ya está
esperando que rusia dé más información
sobre su versión y ayude con las
investigaciones también las
posibilidades de una reacción que vaya
más allá de las palabras que hayan
indicado los políticos alemanes van en
en una posibilidad de sanciones aunque
también aquí hay presión para que
alemania lleva aún una medida más grande
en cuanto al gasoducto nord stream 2 que
es muy importante entre los dos países